The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: OK, so today
is a little bit different.
Today we're going to talk
about yield modeling.
And this is
unabashedly connected
to semiconductor manufacturing--
although I think
many of the things
I talk about here are more
widely applicable, especially
to anything that's large
area manufacturing.
So for example, a few years ago,
I did a roll coding process,
rolling out these giant
plastic sheets of film material
at Kodak.
And defect modeling,
and the yield of--
on a per area basis was
a big deal there as well.
Similarly, many of
the MEMS processes,
thin film processes, yield
modeling associated especially
with defects is very important.
Many of the other ideas
I'll be talking about here
in this lecture
are also connected
to the idea of
assemblies or systems
that consist of many,
many, many, many parts,
whether it may be a failure
of probability or deviations
in individual parts.
And part of the question
is how those aggregate
across the whole system.
So all of the examples here
will be pretty much drawn
from semiconductor
manufacturing,
but I think they are
more broadly applicable.
And perhaps many of the
tools actually developed here
in semiconductor manufacturing
can be used and propagate
to other processes.
So the material will mostly
be drawn from chapter 5,
so on-- need to add a note
as a reading assignment.
This is drawn from
[INAUDIBLE] chapter 5.
But I'm also showing
some examples
from a couple of other papers,
and I'll put those papers
on the website as well.
I realized this morning
they're not up yet.
One is a paper--
sort of a classic
paper by Stapper
on integrated circuit yield
management, yield analysis--
and then a more recent one--
I guess somewhat more recent--
2000-- on predictive
yield modeling.
So both of those will be
available on the website.
So we've already
talked a little bit
about some of the kinds of
variations that lead to--
ultimately can lead to failures,
or failures in specification.
When a deviation in some
continuous parameter
exceeds some spec limit
for normal operation,
we can think of those
as parametric failures.
So we've talked about
things like line width
or so on that might lead
to either direct functional
failure--
meaning it really won't work
because the parameter's too far
away--
or a more fuzzy failure--
this continuous quality
loss in performance,
meaning that I've
gotten such a deviation,
the thing might still
turn on or might operate,
but it does so with decayed
or degraded performance.
In addition to
that, we also want
to talk about random failures.
And these are generally
thought of as more
uncoordinated-- or uncorrelated
random failure in some element.
They aren't necessarily due
to some continuous parameter,
but maybe more of
a lumped failure.
We'll talk in
particular about area
dependent kinds of failures.
In semiconductor manufacturing,
the main source of these
are point defects associated
with very small particles,
dust, or debris that
interfere with the operation
of an electrical
element, generally.
And we previewed some of those
in one of the first lectures.
So we're going to talk about
these kinds of defects.
So the key idea in these is many
of the area-dependent failures
are ones where, depending
on the total square area
of your circuit, you have
more or less opportunity
for those kinds of failures.
So it becomes an
interesting problem
in terms of analyzing the
probabilities associated
with failure for
different sized circuits.
And we'll talk about those.
So here's an example I pulled
out of the [INAUDIBLE] paper
on an integrated
circuit yield tree--
so looking at, say, 100 ASIC
chips that are manufactured,
and what the breakdown
of those might
be in terms of
their ultimate fate.
And in this particular
process, out of the 100 chips,
about 30 are ultimately
shipped to the customer.
So in some sense, you've
got a yield of 30%--
not great, but may not
be entirely unrealistic.
And then, within that 30
chips shipped to the customer,
there's already some
parametric variation
going on that is
essentially a reflection
of that kind of quality
loss degradation
that we talked about before.
Typically, chips are tested,
and we'll do a breakdown,
give you a feel for the
kinds of tests that are done.
But at the end,
they're often tested
for a few key
performance parameters--
in particular, speed.
And then a thing called
speed binning is done,
and you can see here, binning
down into three different speed
categories, where you've
got a few that are operating
at 400 megahertz that--
presumably, you can sell
those chips a little bit more.
350 megahertz you might not
have quite the same price
premium on, and maybe you
have to sell with almost no--
or very limited profit
the 300 megahertz chips,
or something like that.
So there's already still the
driver and process control
to get as tight
control as you can
and push the speed limit
as much as you can.
But what we want to talk
about especially today
are some of the sources for the
chips and sources of variation
and kinds of failures
that are affecting
the chips that are rejected.
And we can break those
down here on this chart
into these other categories.
We've got growth functional
fail, unrepairable cache, speed
less than 300 megahertz,
and all others.
So out of these, first off, the
speed less than 300 megahertz--
that's just our
cut-off on the speed,
and that's probably more
of a parametric variation.
We can break that down and
start to look at what devices,
or what components, or what's
responsible for the slowness
perhaps to improve either
design or manufacturing control.
And here, for example, the clock
speed perhaps is a little bit
too slow, either because
of the interconnect--
the interconnect delay might
be a little bit too long--
or because the transistors,
the active devices
are not quite strong enough.
Knowing those two
could tell you a lot
about the sources of variation.
For example, if
it's interconnect,
it's probably something
with your back-end process.
Some of your resistances
in the interconnect wires
might be a little too high, or
some of those capacitances--
whereas, if you've got an active
device strength failures--
the devices are too slow--
that's likely something to
do with, say, channel length,
or perhaps gate oxide
thicknesses a little too thick.
So it can start to lead to good
knowledge that can give rise
to some improvement efforts.
Now, a little bit more
interesting for today
are these two other categories--
this gross functional
fail and unrepairable cache.
The unrepairable cache--
this might be an ASIC chip,
and it might have different
components or different regions
on it.
Some of it may be
random logic performing
particular combinatorial or
combination logic functions.
But another component is
likely to be embedded memory.
And in fact, as we get to
larger and larger chips
and integration scale, most
of that additional area
these days is going to memory.
So I don't know what percentage
of the new 2 billion transistor
Intel chip is cache, but it's--
AUDIENCE: 90%--
DUANE BONING: 90% is cache--
something you can
do with the area
that helps with performance.
But very interesting
issue here is
these are among the most
dense, most tightly packed
and smallest scaled structures--
highly repeated transistor SRAM
cells, little memory cells.
But there you're
already expecting--
and we'll talk about the
sources of some of these--
you're already expecting some
number of those memory cells
to fail, perhaps because of
particle-oriented defects.
And so one builds in a
certain amount of redundancy
into the cache so
that one can detect--
or into the memory so one can
detect particular failed cells
and program in or fold
in additional redundant
capability.
So that's the repair, the
direct repair of the cache.
But at some point, depending
on where the failure is,
you may not-- you may have
too many of those failures,
or you may fail perhaps even in
some of the redundant switching
in the circuitry.
So you get to a
point where you can't
repair all of those caches.
And so you might start to
look then inside and start
trying to say, OK, what
are the sources there?
Some of those you
might not know--
these unobservable root causes.
Others-- a big chunk maybe due
to these points defects landing
in particularly
damaging locations.
And similarly, if you then
look at growth functional fail,
you just try to-- you
can't even test the memory.
The chip simply won't
power up or won't operate.
One might then also do different
kinds of inspection approaches
to try to detect what the
source of those errors are.
And again, random
defects are typically
a really large part of that.
Systematic defect we'll talk
about a little bit later
as well.
Those might be not quite
random point defects,
but some other failure that's
not quite a parametric failure,
but it's something that's
affecting an awful lot
of the components all together.
And a typical
example here might be
things like overlay
between different layers
of the process.
So everything's just
a little bit off
set in terms of the alignment
from one layer to the next,
causing a substantial yield loss
in lots and lots of components
together.
So what we've bolded here
in that big black rectangle
are these random defects.
And that's one of
the key elements
I want to talk about here are
these point defects associated
with particle-oriented
problems, and how
to model the impact
of these basically
from a statistical
point of view.
But getting back to the
sources or the mental picture
for these kinds of
defects, there's a--
you can be a little bit more
careful with the terminology
here and talk or differentiate--
talk about the
difference between, say,
particles and defects.
So a particle-- you can think
of any kind of foreign matter
that might be sitting
on the surface
or might be embedded
in a layer on the chip.
Now, some of these
might be benign,
so a particle is not
necessarily a defect.
A defect would be
when it affects
some functionality of the chip.
So a picture here, qualitatively
giving you this sense--
we've got three
different dust particles
on a particular feature on--
lined up with particular
features on the mask.
And one can easily imagine
that perhaps this particle,
if it's conductive and those
crosshatch areas are also
conductive-- or
say, metal lines--
that's going to be a
problem, potentially.
Actually, if someplace
else, these two things
are the same wire, maybe
it's not a problem.
So it's actually
kind of interesting.
It depends on both
the particular layout
and on the location
of a particle,
whether it will lead to
degradation or functional
failure.
You can also imagine
perhaps this structure,
this particle might be a defect.
In what case would
this be a defect?
Your initial
inclination might be,
if I'm just looking
at this layer,
it's not necessarily bridging
from this wire to that wire.
So why would that be a problem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
capacitor then [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Right.
So if it's conductive and
these two are conductive,
I might have some additional
capacity of linking even
within that one layer.
But I'm trying to give
hints, saying one layer here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This direction.
DUANE BONING: Yes,
in the z-direction--
remember also, we've got
build up of many, many layers.
Remember that stacking of
the interconnect layer.
And even within the device
layer, there's many--
so it can propagate
potentially bridge or short
or cause deviations in the next
layer of processing as well.
How about this last one here?
Is that a problem?
I'm seeing maybe,
yes, yes, probably.
Why do you think
that's a problem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
resistance on the [INAUDIBLE]??
DUANE BONING: Well,
if it were conductive,
it might not reduce
the resistance--
or increase the resistance.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Right.
Yeah.
So a couple of examples
there is certainly,
if it's non-conductive,
what you've got now
is increased resistance in
that segment right there,
which can also cascade
to reliability problems.
A well-known problem
is migration,
where basically, the electron
flux of high current flowing
very, very high current
density up in the 10
to the fifth to 10 to the
sixth per centimeter squared
kind of amps centimeter
squared can actually
cause the metal atoms to move.
So they will migrate
with the current flow--
or with the electronic
flow, and you'll
get-- you can very
often get voiding,
especially in these
particular locations,
where the wire gets
thinner and thinner,
and ultimately, in
fact, may be an open.
But again, maybe it's OK.
Maybe you've got enough
latitude and you're not really
pushing current through there.
So one side message here is
you never want particles.
You always want to
minimize the number
of particles and the
opportunity for failure.
But the other
message, of course,
is how bad they
are kind of depend
on particulars of your circuit
and your specifications.
So we'll actually
talk a little bit
about some of the
tools that have
evolved to be able to analyze
some of those sorts of things.
So I've talked a lot about opens
and-- or I guess short circuits
here.
You might lead to
an open circuit,
in terms of losing
a conductive path,
but there's also a lot of
other kinds of failures
that-- where we're dust
particles or other defects
might impact the
device operation so
that you get failure.
It could be, for example in
an active device, where you've
got perturbation of
transistor parameters,
not necessarily just
a short or an open.
So what is yield?
Very qualitatively,
yield is the percentage
of parts meeting
some specification--
set of specification.
But what we often do
in IC yield terminology
is look at different
points in the process--
flow or different
points of testing--
and we'll differentiate the
yield in some cases that way.
And the other is we'll
sometimes break down
what kind of yield losses
or what size of a bucket
we're talking about for
thinking about yield.
By size of a bucket, what
we've got in semiconductor
manufacturing is a-- and many
other manufacturing process is
a very hierarchical--
spatially as well as
temperately-- structure.
What I mean by that is we've got
within the fab many different
lots of wafers.
Each lot maybe is 25 wafers
being processed together.
Within each lot, I've got--
of those 25 wafers, I pull
out one wafer and I've got,
what, 50 to thousands
of chips on it.
So I can talk about
yield in terms of,
well, what fraction of lots
make it through the line?
It's possible I might scrap
a whole lot of wafers.
Or what fraction of the wafers
within the lot make it through?
I might have a
dropped wafer, and you
might break it, or other kinds
of large-scale mechanical
failure along the line.
You're not going to
scrap the whole lot
if one wafer breaks, but--
so the actual percentage
of wafers that
make it to the end of the line.
And that's just,
mechanically, have
the wafers made it to the end?
Then you can start
looking and saying,
OK, what fraction
of those wafers
appear to be coarsely
are grossly within spec?
And then similarly,
you start looking
at the die and say,
which of the die
are likely to be
able to function?
What percentage of
die yield do I have?
Before I go and I invest the
two hours of intense burn in
and testing for
each of those chips,
and packaging of
I might then also want to
do some on-chip electrical
testing.
And then, once it's
packaged, I might
do a full functional
testing at speed
to try to determine which
fraction of those are working.
So we've got some of these
different terminologies here.
So wafer yield is just--
actually, let me go
to the next picture.
This graphically defines some
of these different yields.
We've drawn the
wafer fab itself,
the sequence of the processing
steps shown up above.
And very often, inline tests are
being performed all the time--
not necessarily on every
piece of equipment or test
of the wafer after
every individual fab
step, but one will be making
measurements at various points
along the flow to check on
the status of the wafer,
as well as check on the
status of the equipment.
One might also have some amount
of real-time measurements
actually on the
equipment itself.
And a whole
additional problem is
correlating equipment
measurements
to what's happening
on the wafer--
that's especially
useful for debug,
but it tends not
to be used directly
for yield calculations.
So it is possible that, as
you're coming along here,
you may scrap out wafers based
on some of the inline tests.
Then what's often referred
to as the back end--
although it's kind of
confusing, because front end
and back end can mean
different things,
depending on who you're
talking to in an IC fab.
If you're within the
IC fab, often they'll
talk front end processing
as the transistor formation
and back end as the
interconnect formation.
But once you emerge out of the
fab itself into the testing,
that's also referred
to as the back end.
Once the wafer has
finished its fabrication,
and is now going
both in the testing
and then dicing up into
individual chips for packaging,
that's also referred
to as the back end.
So we've got some wafer fab.
We've got wafer yield that
maybe those wafers that
make it through the very
coarse electrical test.
Then you do a more detailed
functional test on each die,
and as pictured here, the
die yield or functional yield
would be those fraction
that are making it through.
Those set of a little bit more
elaborate functional tests--
now you go ahead and
package up those--
just those chips
that are successfully
passing those
tests, and then you
might do a binning or parametric
test on all of the chips.
There is another
additional failure point
that's really important.
And this distinction between
yield and reliability
is a little bit fuzzy.
We've got die yield as being--
the full parametric die
yield as those chips that
meet all the specifications.
You ship them to the customer.
They go into parts.
And three months later,
they fail in the field.
That's also a yield
loss, in some sense.
It's more described
as a reliability loss,
but that's that field
loss can be really bad.
You really want to avoid that,
because the costs associated
typically with dealing with
in-field failures is very high.
What's interesting
is, very often--
and I'm not going to talk
too much about it here,
but what's very
often the case is
there is a relationship
between reliability failures
and yield loss sources
back in the fab.
The intuition is not
that hard to imagine.
We even talked about it
back on in this picture.
If I have a low yielding process
because, on a critical metal
layer, I've got lots of
point defects leading
to these kinds of problems, it
might survive through the test,
but that problem
of, say, migration
might be more prone
to occur in the field.
So in general, actually,
yield problems in the fab
can actually be a
great warning signal
that you may have ultimate
reliability failures.
So what we want to do
is try to get a handle
on ways to model and
understand the yield loss,
and be able to make
some predictions
not just for-- based on
historical data for product A,
but also make some
predictions for product B
on your line-- what you might
expect the yield loss to be.
What's interesting here is we've
done so much with the Gaussian
distribution--
this is a great case where
the normal distribution
is generally not the
operative distribution--
that the probability functions
of the binomial and Poisson
statistics are
typically more at work
with random kinds
of point failures.
So we'll review that
just real briefly.
And then what I think
is really interesting
is the spatial nature
of some of these kinds
of defect processes,
this area dependence.
So we want to talk about how--
what some of the basic
modeling approaches
are for area-dependent failures.
So earlier in the
semester, we already
talked about the
binomial distribution.
I think this may be the
same slide, or almost
the same slide.
Remember, the
binomial distribution
is kind of a nice one
dealing with just this notion
of success or failure.
So if I have a point defect
that leads to success or failure
with some probability
p, and I've
got now lots of opportunities
for that failure--
n trials for that particular
failure or success--
then we can count up or
associate the probability
of some number of successes x
using a binomial distribution.
This very often is, in fact,
probably the most important
underlying function--
it and its approximation
on the next slide--
for thinking about
ways to aggregate
when I've got
multiple opportunities
or multiple
structures, and I want
to estimate, given
my probability,
that any one-- say,
any one chip on a wafer
is bad, assuming they
were uncorrelated,
and just due to
random defects, what
is the probability that, in
a wafer with 100 chips on it,
I would have 95, 96, 9-- or
better number of chips actually
coming out?
What's my probability associated
with the yield of at least 95%
on that?
And that falls out directly
from a binomial distribution.
You could add up then
the probabilities of F,
with x being 95, 96, 97, 98,
99, 100, and there you go.
Now, the Poisson distribution
we also talked about,
and this is a good
one when we have
in particular very large numbers
of opportunities for failure,
but the failure probability
for any one of those occurring
is exceptionally small.
So we'll talk about this,
especially when we're
talking about, say, the tens
of thousands or millions
of devices or structures
within an individual chip.
Typically, binomial,
the probabilities
of failure for any one
chip are fairly large,
and the numbers of
chips on the wafer
are fairly moderate, so you
can directly use the binomial.
But when we start to talk about
very, very small probabilities
of failure, the Poisson ends up
being very, very interesting.
And this is the case also where
you start to not just think
about discrete
failure opportunities,
but it's more useful to think
about a failure rate lambda.
So for example, what-- if
you have a particular failure
rate per unit area, just
as with queuing systems,
you have an opportunity
for arrival per unit time.
Now think, I've got the
opportunity for an arrival
of a defect per unit area.
How does the probability
then, for different areas,
give rise to the
different probabilities
of certain numbers of
successes or failures?
So this ends up
being very useful
for defect-oriented,
area-dependent oriented
modeling, very often.
It's also great
for any other case
where you've got just a large
number of discrete failures.
And a typical one
that we'll talk about
are things like via yield
failures or contact yield
failures.
These are the little
electrical connections
from one layer to the
next in the wiring,
or from the wiring down
to the transistor level.
You can imagine any one
metal layer may have millions
to perhaps, in some
layers, billions of these.
The opportunity for
failure of any one of those
is exceptionally
small, but you've
got a heck of a lot of them.
And so then you
might want to ask,
what's the probability of having
perfect operation within that?
So I saw a hand somewhere.
Was there question?
AUDIENCE: No, you
answered [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Great, great--
OK, so we're going
to be using those.
Here is the via example.
We could use the
binomial distribution.
Well, first, let me give you
a couple of definitions here.
So we're looking, say, at
one particular metal layer,
and the probability of
failure for any one via
is exceptionally small.
We'll call that p sub v,
probability of failure
for that.
However, again, we have
n opportunities or n vias
in each layer of the chip.
So you might want to
ask the question, well,
what's the probability that
I have one via failure,
then I have 10--
I have failures in some range?
Or ultimately, you
want to really ask
the question, what's the
probability I have zero
via failures, so I
don't have any wiring
problems on that chip?
One could go ahead and directly
use the binomial distribution.
Alternatively, what we
can start to think of as,
what is a failure rate
or the average number
of total via failures, lambda
v, for those vias on a layer?
So here, we're essentially--
what the heck happened?
That's supposed to be an equals.
So this failure rate
is simply the product
of the opportunities in the
individual failure, which
gives you per chip
now this failure rate.
What is the average number
of failures-- via failures
per chip for that layer?
And now you can use the
Poisson distribution, again,
because the conditions of
very small P, very large n.
And just plugging in, we've
got this expression here.
And again, what I said is what
we're really interested in
is the probability that
the whole chip is good,
that none of these via
failures are catastrophic.
None of them occur.
And so I'm really looking
for the probability
that x equals 0--
I have zero via failures.
With an average number of
failures of three per chip,
I'd like to know, well,
what's the likelihood then--
what's my probability that
the whole chip is good?
It's not zero.
It's not 100%, because
on average, I've
got three defects, or three
via failures per chip.
But I've got some out
there in a tail that
are still going to be good.
And so even with
non-zero failure rates--
fact, it's hard to imagine that
you have a full zero failure
rate--
you can still have good chips.
Now, of course,
you'd like lambda
to be perhaps less
than 1 on average.
But now we can basically use
Poisson statistics to aggregate
and calculate, given individual
failure likelihoods or failure
rates, what the
probabilities are
that the whole assembly works.
Question here--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Right.
Right.
In fact, what this has already
done is multiplied by the area,
and so the area multiplication
here was per chip.
So you ultimately get to
some per unit unitless.
So lambda is unitless
in this case.
We'll see other examples
when we do some other area
dependencies, where you might
be looking within the chip,
and actually explicitly adding
in or calculating some area,
and then multiplying the failure
per unit area times the area
that you're sensitive to to
get to a lambda-like parameter.
OK?
This is just a little example--
I'm actually not going
to go through it--
that's just working through
the two cases for the binomial
and Poisson distributions--
particularly in the case when
n is large and pv as small.
So this is just looking
at the particular binomial
distribution when x is 0, or
the Poisson distribution for x
equals 0 for no failures
in the two cases,
and just showing that, for
small lambda or for small pv,
they both go to the
same approximate result.
So we have our
simplest yield model.
We have the binomial
distribution,
which you might
use, for example--
aggregating chip yield.
We've got via kinds of
individual failure models--
so per component
or a failure rate,
and how to aggregate those on
a per unit or per area basis.
But I do want to get, actually,
to exactly the question you
just asked.
How do we get our minds
around the situation
when I've got those little dust
particles falling on some area,
and I'm trying to understand the
area dependence of the circuit?
And so what we're
going to do is actually
want to build a yield model
that's a little bit more
broken out, that explicitly
allows us to make predictions
based on the area
of the circuit,
the area of opportunity
for these failures,
and a defect density or
knowledge about the number
of defects on
average per unit area
that we are likely to have.
And the reason is, if
you think about it,
the chip gets bigger and bigger.
It's got larger area.
And if it's-- only takes
one defect to fail,
the larger it becomes, the more
likely that chip is to fail.
So one key driver in this
that interacts a little bit
with design is, how
big can I make the chip
without incurring
undue yield loss,
just because I'm going to have
some likelihood of defects
per unit area?
So we want to understand
that interplay.
We'll start with
just overall area,
but quickly get to this
notion of a critical area
on the chip, which
is really just
that area where the defect
has to fall or a particle
has to fall in order for
it to actually be a defect,
and cause an electrical
open, or a short,
or some other fault, some
other failure in the circuit.
So how might we go
about modeling these?
Well, first, to help
with the mental model
here, with spatial defects,
we're going to make,
in the simplest yield
model, a few assumptions.
And then I'll show you,
over the course of time,
some of the improved versions
of these defect-oriented models
that have arrived that account
for a little bit more--
or additional effects or relax
a few of these assumptions.
So what I've pictured here--
[INAUDIBLE] it does show up--
is a wafer with some
number of chips on it--
I don't know-- 100,
150 different chips,
and a splattering of a
few little red particles.
These actually are defects.
Each one of these
red particles falls
into place that causes a
failure, some kind of a short.
They're big enough that they
actually sort things out.
And you can start to see,
essentially, an assumption here
is that each one
of these defects
corresponds to killing one
chip in this simple model.
Some other assumptions
are they are, in fact,
randomly distributed by
Poisson kinds of statistics.
They're also randomly
spatially distributed.
Knowing where one
defect is tells you
nothing about where
another defect is.
So they are spatially
uncorrelated.
So those are some of
the initial assumptions,
and under those
assumptions, what
has been observed is a
very interesting or natural
relationship between
the density, d0--
the average number per
unit area of defects--
in this case, I've
got, what, 1, 2, 3, 4--
eight defects here per the
total unit area of the wafer,
and the number of or percentage
of chips that fail, depending
on the area of each chip.
And it's pretty obvious,
especially if I go to extremes.
What if the area of my chip were
the area of the entire wafer?
I had one chip per wafer.
If I had eight
defects on average
per wafer, that means
pretty much every wafer,
every time, I'm going to for
sure have most likely at least
one defect, and my yield's
going to be extremely low.
At some point,
though, my chip size
gets small enough
that this assumption
of every defect killing only
one chip is a very good one.
And then I saturate out to
basically a relationship
that's very close to
just being determined
by counting the number of
defects I have per unit area.
And what was done--
and this is either
in the Stapper paper
or referred to another
paper from Stapper--
is very early on,
this dependence
on the chip area and that
percentage functioning
was observed, and it was
observed to be exponential.
So this is empirical
observation that
gives credence to this
notion of the Poisson
statistics are really
what's at work,
that exponential
dependence on area.
And what he basically
found is that,
as the chip area in square
millimeters went up,
the yield went down.
So when the chip area
was small enough--
very close to 100% yield.
And then-- this is
on a log scale--
notice, this is on a long scale.
So there appeared
to be roughly a--
on the log scale,
a linear decrease
in yield as the wafer area--
or excuse me-- as the
chip area increased--
so that kind of an
exponential dependence.
And so very early on, the first
model that was really used
was a Poisson defect model that
basically treated each defect
as a point--
said, again, these
same assumptions.
Each defect results in a
fault, and these things
are spatially uncorrelated.
So then what you
can really do is
start to say, for any
circuit, any chip,
with some critical
area a sub c--
so that's the area
within the chip
that's sensitive to the
falling of these particles--
maybe ac is equal to the
whole chip area, maybe not--
and some defect
density, then the yield
is simply exponential--
e to the minus ac times d0.
And recognize,
that ac times d0--
that gives rise to something
like a lambda parameter,
a failure rate
kind of parameter.
Now, he did a little
bit of further breakdown
here, which I'm not going
to go too much into.
This actually distinguishes
between a given circuit
and then the whole chip, which
might have n circuits on it.
Looking individually at each
critical circuit on the chip,
you could say for that
particular circuit--
the wiring pattern, say,
of that particular circuit
for a metal layer--
what is the critical area
a sub c for that layer?
And you can get the yield
statistics for metal layer 3
for circuit--
maybe it's the adder circuit
in the upper left corner
of the device--
or the chip.
And then, if you
have n circuits, each
with a critical area A sub
C, for all of them to work,
you've just got a
multiplicative probability
so that your yield is
a multiplicative yield
factor for all of those
individual circuits.
So you can read
this as your yield
for an individual circuit,
just to the n-th power.
And so what they're doing here
is just simply aggregating
and saying the
total critical area
might be across all
of your circuits.
If each one of them
had equal area a sub c,
the total area would be
just the product n times ac.
Or you might do a
summation, might simply
add up all of the
different critical areas.
Now, an expansion on this
starts to pull in a little bit
more statistics.
And in particular, one of the
really interesting statistics
is an observation that not every
wafer observes the same defect
density--
that there, in fact, is
a probability density
function associated
with the defect density.
Some wafers might
see larger numbers
of defect per unit area.
Other wafers may see fewer.
In the natural
operation-- you've
got the fab as clean
as you can make it--
there's still a range of
different defect densities
you expect on any one wafer.
So the first extension
is to characterize
the probability density
function associated
with defect density--
just number of
defects per unit area.
And now you can integrate up
what your expected yield is,
accounting for
the fact that I've
got a whole range of, or a
whole PDF for different defect
densities.
And so the first extension
here is referred to
as the Murphy yield
model, discussed, again,
in [INAUDIBLE].
And all we do is we
have, for any given d,
we have our Poisson
yield model, and then
I'm simply averaging
that over my PDF.
So I'm integrating that over
all possible defect densities.
Now, we can get back to
the Poisson yield model,
and now we actually
recognize that that's
the special case when we
assume there's only one defect
density, and it
applies to every wafer.
That is, our PDF, our f of
d, is just a delta function.
All of the defects are at d0.
So we can recover and get back
to our Poisson yield model.
But what's interesting
now is, depending
on the statistics associated
with defect densities,
I might end up with different
final yield formulas.
And so a number of
different-- whoops--
yield distributions, PDF
associated with defect density
have been explored, and
then some empirical fits
done to data--
yield data to try to see which
matched a little bit better.
And what's nice is there
are at least a few PDFs
that, if you plug them
into that integral,
you're going to have a
closed form solution.
So for example, if you have
a uniform probability density
function associated
with defect density,
that yields or gives rise to
this uniform yield formula,
which is no longer exponential--
or just an exponential.
It's also got a 1 minus the--
this exponential in a scaling
factor--
can also do it for a
triangular distribution.
You get a squared version.
If I plug in a
Gaussian, we already
know that an integral over a
Gaussian is kind of nasty--
doesn't have a
closed form solution.
So it's not directly integrable.
One can certainly
do it numerically,
and things like the
phi function does that.
The Murphy yield
model was done back
when people really wanted
closed form kinds of solutions.
Oh, I thought I had a picture.
Here we go.
So here's a comparison of some
of these different PDFs that
have been examined.
Again, Poisson assumes
everything is at a d0--
should be a d0 there--
a uniform distribution.
I might have defect densities
across that whole range,
or some triangular
distribution where
you might, in fact, restrict it
in some additional form related
to some d0--
or an exponentially decaying
defect density function.
What was interesting is, if
you go back to the literature,
Seeds proposed that--
based on some experimental
data, that an exponential defect
density distribution
appeared to make sense.
First off, the
qualitative reason
was its vanishingly
small likelihood
that you've got lots and lots
of defects, because if you do,
your overall process yield
is not going to be very good,
and so you would have done
process correction or process
development to remove that.
But as the defect density
gets smaller and smaller,
a good manufacturing process--
that's where you want to be.
You want to have much,
much higher likelihood
of small numbers of defects
per unit area than high ones.
So this is not really a
statement about physics.
It's a statement about
manufacturing operation
that drives a particular kind
of shape of defect density
distributions.
It says all of the--
or a huge amount
of energy is put
in to driving down the
defect density distribution.
And what that should
lead to is something
like an exponential
falloff, as pictured here.
You would expect and hope that
your manufacturing process
would have a much higher
likelihood of a small number
of defects per unit area.
And what's nice is, when you
plug that in, you can get
a closed form
expression that's--
that, for the exponential
defect density,
is very nice and simple.
Question--
AUDIENCE: Does that really
make sense, though, compared
to, say, using half a
Gaussian instead with, say,
v centered at 0 and just
cropping half of it.
It kind of seems
as you approach 0,
it actually becomes
more difficult to remove
those last couple of defects,
rather than going exponentially
up that curve, that it
kind of flattens off.
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
So the question is, what
really is the defect density
distribution?
And does this make sense?
Especially with the singularity,
as the defect density
goes to 0, what's the
relative probability?
Might you model this with a
Gaussian or a half Gaussian?
There's all kinds of arguments.
And it's actually difficult to
get enough data to really nail
down the distribution.
Think of how many
wafers, if you will--
to get a very
careful description
of defect density
per unit area--
on average you might need.
It's hard to fully get the
amount of data that you need.
So you're really getting
a few data points in here
that you're trying to get at
least the right trend with.
And so it actually doesn't
matter too critically, as long
as you've got the basic
essence of the shape.
And I will show you
at the end a few
of the kinds of
test structures that
are used to try to approximate
or get at these defect density
distributions.
And in fact, what is very
often done, just to give you
a little bit of a peek--
people might use the
exponential with a fit
to just a couple of points
or a couple of parameters.
OK, so that's basically
the Seeds model,
and that often is used.
But I want to return to a
couple of other further extended
models and give you a little
bit of a feel for them,
because the arguments about
defect density distributions
continue.
But also, reassessing
or looking back
at some of the other
assumptions that I've mentioned,
arguments about
those also exist.
And one of the
most important ones
is this notion of no spatial
correlation in your defect
locations.
Rather than show this,
let me show this first.
So we assumed the
picture over on the left,
that all of your
defects were randomly
distributed across the wafer.
What's very often
observed in practice
is that these defects tend
to cluster near each other.
And maybe there's some process
going on in your chamber that
occasionally splattering
particles, accelerating
particles in some direction.
And so those may naturally
send multiple particles
all together, and they may very
often tend to cluster together.
So that is very interesting.
If, instead of each
and every particle
being spatially distributed
and causing a fault
on an individual
chip, now, well, I've
got multiple particles
all falling and perhaps
causing defects on
these two chips,
but now that assumption
that every single defect is
causing its own unique kill
event is no longer really true.
You really can't keep
killing the same chip
and causing
additional yield loss.
So if you've got clustering
of your defects, in fact,
you may be in better
shape than you
would have assumed per the count
of defects over on the left.
And a distribution that has an
additional parameter in it--
this alpha parameter--
that gives a defect
density distribution
with an extra degree
of freedom that you
can play with this shape--
not necessarily even Gaussian.
But some other
amounts of skewness
away from that exponential is
a negative binomial or gamma
probability distribution
that gives rise
to this negative binomial model.
And so empirically, there's
this additional alpha parameter
that lets one tweak, or fit
your data to tweak the defect
density distribution.
So if you wanted something
that was a little bit more
like a Gaussian or
a half Gaussian,
but maybe behaved a
little bit differently
right near your
low defect density,
you've got that opportunity.
And what's nice about
it is it actually
correlates or relates to this
notion of spatial clustering
of your defects.
So there's a reasonable
physical explanation
for these situations.
Yes, question--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: I'm sorry.
Say that again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Oh, well, if
they're doing the d0 Murphy
model, it's probably--
they might be just using
the delta function--
simple kind of a model.
But you'd actually have
to probe a little bit,
because they might also
have a clustering parameter,
and really, then what's going
on is something like this.
So where your d0
is in here, there
is still a scaling factor
to this distribution.
You can see the d0 in here.
So they might be using, in
fact, a negative binomial yield
model.
In fact, I think
that, right now, this
is a dominant
model that is used,
with clustering accounted for.
And so the d0 is
still your average--
it's your central scaling or
average on this distribution.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 10
years or 5 years, then
that [INAUDIBLE]
changing [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: So the question
is, for a long lifetime,
how do these parameters change?
And generally, they do
change on your fab--
not necessarily the
lifetime of your product
so much, because I think of--
your d0 tends to be more a
characteristic of your unit
process or your
integrated process.
But as you learn more, you
have this yield learning,
where you hope you drive your
defect density down with time--
drive your particle size down.
So you do continue to
improve the process.
In fact, in some of the
yield projections for product
you might run in
your fab in a year,
you might also include
some projections
on what you think
d0 will improve to,
based on historical
trends over time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yes, yes--
typically, perhaps
more with the d0--
probably less
projections on alpha.
Alpha tends to be
this clustering, which
has two limit that
I'll talk about--
low clustering and very
highly, tightly clustered.
I don't think that's assumed
to change that much with time.
But the d0 is the main
thing that goes down
with improved processing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: They
should, whether they're
drawn to actually
integrate out to 1 or not.
But they are all still defect
[INAUDIBLE] probability density
functions.
So we do have this alpha
clustering parameter.
What's nice is, amazingly, you
plug that PDF into the integral
with an exponential Poisson
kernel in e to the minus acd,
you get a closed form
yield formula here,
as shown at the bottom,
which has the alpha
clustering parameter in it.
And we can take two limits.
One limit is the large
alpha limit, which
is very little clustering.
So think of maybe
alpha as the distance
between individual defects,
and as that gets large,
you don't have any clustering.
And that limit converges
to the Poisson model.
And in the very
small alpha limit,
with very, very strong
clustering, that actually
converges in the limit for alpha
going to 0 to the Seeds model
that we saw earlier, which
was the pure exponential.
So you see, as alpha
gets smaller and smaller,
this approach is more and more
the exponential defect density
model.
Turns out that,
generally, people
are fitting based on
experimental data, their D0.
And they're also fitting,
empirically, alpha.
And alpha tends to be related
both to the clustering,
but also a little bit to
the sensitivity of your type
of circuit to clustering.
So it's not purely--
if I did this just
on blanket wafers
and looked at the clustering,
that may actually not
tell me what is going to happen
for different kinds of product.
So you actually might end up
with different components of
or different
products, whether it
be a memory product or a
microprocessor product,
or different components
on a big multi-product
that has a lot of
memory cache on it,
and also has the
combinational logic on it.
You might have slightly
different yield model
components or slightly
different alphas for those two
different cases, and
you would fit those.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] is
actually designed using
different alpha parameters--
DUANE BONING: Interesting--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
So the observation, if you
didn't hear that in Singapore,
was that, in practice, with
those memory redundancy
schemes, those
also affect alpha,
and so it's an empirical fitting
process with different kinds
of redundancy to see
how that affects alpha--
and what your ultimate yield
would be based on that.
OK, so so far, we've talked
about a probability density
associated with the number
of defects per unit area.
We can also think about
another probability function,
another statistical
relationship.
So far, we've talked about
every defect abstractly
as being infinitesimally small.
So one defect doesn't cover
20 different chips, right?
It's just infinitesimally small.
But what if there is an area
dependence to the size--
or a probability associated
with the size of those defects?
That could interact
very importantly
with some of those original
shorting and open physics
that we talked about earlier.
So for example, if I have
wiring lines like this,
and I'm really worried
about either open or short,
and my defect is substantially
smaller than either the spacing
or the width of the line,
it can fall almost anywhere
and not cause at least
an immediate failure--
might still be a reliability
or a parametric resistance
change that I'd
be worried about--
whereas, if the defect
were much larger,
it can fall almost
anywhere on my circuit
and cause either
an open or a short.
So the effect of particles
of different sizes
can be very different,
and so I might also
want to characterize the size
distribution of particles.
And the interaction of
those science distributions
with the particular
feature sizes on my circuit
is going to be very important.
So it interacts with this
notion then of a critical area.
Let's see if I've
got a better picture.
Nope, this is pretty much it.
There is a formal notion
of critical error--
area for any particular defect
size that you can actually
analyze for your particular
layout and say, which area--
which fraction of the
area on that layer
does the center of the particle
have to fall in order for it
to cause either an
open or a short?
Let me try to erase
this a little bit.
So for example,
the critical area
perhaps associated with the
smallest particle may be 0.
It can fall anywhere
and not cause a problem.
This particle is perhaps
a more interesting one,
in that maybe it's exactly
equal to the size of--
actually, let's do an
example [INAUDIBLE]
Let's do an example
where I've got something
that's, say, equal to--
or just slightly larger
than the spacing size.
But in some places,
I've got wires where--
and spaces that are
smaller than that,
such as pictured here, but
I've also got other places--
let's say, I have
now another wire
up here, where the spacing is
larger than the particle size.
Now this same particle
can fall right there
and not cause a short.
So you can calculate across your
entire particular layout what
is the band where the
center of the particle
has to fall to cause
either an open or a short
and some up that
area of sensitivity
for failure for
each of the layers.
So there's this interaction
between a critical area
per particle size, and
then a distribution
associated with the
particle sizes that are very
important to also characterize.
And here are some examples--
again, going way back--
for defect size distributions.
These are back
characterized in mils.
Anybody know what a mil is?
Thousandth of an inch,
or about 25 microns--
so these are giant,
giant particles.
We have driven down
defect sizes a bit.
But what is very interesting
is the same trend
has continued to be observed--
that there is generally
believed to be something
close to an exponential
dependence in defect size,
not just in the number
of defects as well.
And that exponential-- or
power law kind of dependence
is very often used in
modeling the size distribution
for defects.
Now, there's a couple
of parameters-- this n
and this p, which,
again, end up being
technology dependent
and generally fitting
parameters to the data.
So now, if we take in that
notion of a distribution
in defect sizes and the
probability associated
with that, one can
form an aggregate sort
of approximate parameter.
And so sometimes that's
also the d0 that is quoted.
So it's not only averaged in
terms of numbers per area,
but it's also kind of a boiled
down approximate parameter
giving you a sense of the basic
central moment of the size
distribution as well.
But if you really wanted to
do careful defect modeling,
you actually need to know
the p parameters and the n
parameters.
You would like to have
that full defect size
distribution at hand.
Here are some examples.
The typical ranges
of that exponent--
I guess it's a p exponent
in the previous slide--
is two, three, four.
And it may depend on
the defect failure mode
that you're looking
at-- so for example,
extra metal or short versus
missing metal and opened.
They may have slightly different
sensitivity to that defect size
as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] more
distributions [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: This is
basically this power law.
1/x to the p is the assumed--
AUDIENCE: That's [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But for [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: For the d0,
the d0 is actually still
not counting-- adding
in the defect density.
That will come in in
the other distribution.
Oh, OK, I did have a slide.
I think I've already
explained this,
but this is talking again
about the critical area
for different size dependencies.
And what's interesting
is then you can also
start to produce a plot of this
critical area versus defect
size.
And what's really important
here is very intuitive trends
that, for larger defects,
I've got larger critical area.
More part of my chip
is sensitive to it.
But once it gets smaller than
a certain dimension, when
my defects tend to be smaller
than my minimum feature size
on the device, I
start to be less
sensitive to immediate failures.
So if they're a fraction--
your particles are a fraction
of your minimum dimension.
And that's good, because
you probably have
lots of defects of those sizes.
It's very hard to
get rid of those.
Now, what you can do is
start to put these together.
You aggregate these.
If you have a defect
size distribution that
goes as one of these
1/x to the p's, you
can start to try to empirically
fit that to your data.
One thing that happens with
these distributions, of course,
is the same thing
you were worried
about with the exponential.
When x gets really small,
that goes sky high--
1 over a very small number.
And so what people
basically do is
they're mostly worried about
the defect sizes larger
than their minimum feature size.
And then they'll basically
truncate it either
as a constant or, in fact,
as a linear drop-off,
once you get down below
some minimum size.
I should have drawn
that near x0 instead.
So there is a size at which it's
hard to either detect these,
and you don't care
about them, and so
you're not really
trying to model
that part of this distribution.
In one of the first
lectures, I gave you
a little bit of a preview
and an example here
of how you might measure these
defect size distributions.
Characterization test
vehicles, especially early
in process development,
might be used
to try to characterize the
capability of the process
in terms of these--
both your defect density,
but also your defect sizes.
And imagine now that
I've got a whole array
of these nested
metal lines that I
can make electrical
measurements or connections to.
And if I have now
a defect that's
kind of small in general--
or usually-- it might be even so
small that I rarely get short,
but I might get some amount
of resistance change in these
lines--
versus other defects that are so
big that they start to bridge,
on average, two or three lines.
You can start to build up
some electrical measure
of the likelihood of having--
or the relative counts of
defects of different sizes.
So here's an empirical--
this is, again,
from a 2003 paper.
You can start to see that 1/x
to the p empirical relationship,
and it gives you a sense for how
you can actually measure those.
So now you can have a
more careful definition
of the critical area, where
you have your defect size
distribution.
I might use dsd
to indicate that.
So there's our defect
size distribution,
that 1/x to the p--
again, really only worrying
about it above some x0.
And then you also
have this probability
of failure, which folds in
this notion of critical area.
You can actually
look at your layout
and say, if I've got
a defect of this size,
this is my probability
of failure integrated
across my whole chip.
And now you can aggregate
the two of those
into a net total critical area.
So all I'm doing
is saying there is
a probability of failure
associated with defects
of different sizes.
The defect is really small.
Again, I have that critical area
plot, where I'm down in here,
and it's very small.
But empirically, for
my particular circuit,
I may have different critical
area dependence curves, where
I aggregate the total pof.
And then I look at
the product of those
two, integrate it
up, and that gives me
a good aggregate sense--
which really says where I'm
mostly worried is in this range
here, where I've
got defects that
are close to my feature size.
The small ones aren't
going to kill me.
The bigger ones are
Really big ones are not going
to kill me, because there's not
that many big ones.
So really, it tells you
the area to worry about.
OK, I'm going to skip
over most of this.
I just want you to get
a feel for this notion
of critical area.
And this is an
area where there's
a lot of design automation
tools, where it can actually
look at your particular
layout and start
to do those kinds of
drawings that I showed you
for critical area, if you
will, and shade in-- maybe
a little hard to see, but
you can shade in and say,
what is the gray critical area
for that particular circuit?
Where am I sensitive
to the likelihood
of a short for defects
of a particular size?
Where am I sensitive?
Where would a-- the
center of a particle
have to fall in order
to cause an open?
Or where might I have
to have a particle
fall that would cause a short
between two different layers?
And you can actually do these
calculations for your layout,
and then do design
modifications that
would come back in
and say, oh, if that's
my critical area where I might
be susceptible to a break,
let's make those lines
a little bit wider.
If I make those
lines wider, I've
improved my yield, because
now, if the particle falls
in those lines, I'm not
as likely to actually have
an open failure.
So there is yield
improvement strategies
that go with these
notions of critical area,
and the probabilities
associated with them.
The last notion
is simply you can
integrate these up and
get aggregate notions
of overall yield.
This is also described in
[INAUDIBLE] Just reminding
you-- there's also other
kinds of yield detractors,
where you might have
gross yield losses,
and so you might have a
global factor y0 that's
associated with alignment
errors or other kinds
of gross factors.
And then this last
is a little example
that you can read about in
[INAUDIBLE],, which is basically
simply saying, in
practice, your chip yield
is all so aggregated
that it doesn't really
tell you what's gone wrong.
So very often, you
want to slice yield
into your different layers--
your different process
layers, or slice them
into different
functional blocks--
maybe the memory or cache
block, a logic block--
and basically look
at where you are
most sensitive to yield loss.
For example, that 95% yield
loss factor or via 2 inside
of your SRAM might
be where you're
losing most of your yield.
There's quite a bit of
development of these test chips
that have those things like
those nested via or nested
snake structures in them so
that one can characterize
defectivity distributions,
as well as sensitivity
of different kinds of
circuits to those failures.
So that's a whirlwind tour
there of semiconductor yield,
these notions of not
just functional yield
that we saw last
time, but also this--
or parametric yield, but
defect yield as well.
And you'll have a little
bit of fun playing around
with some of these notions
of area-dependent yield,
which I think is really
kind of the cool idea,
the important idea in yield
modeling for semiconductors.
OK, so we'll see you
again on Thursday.
Thursday is the quiz.
I think here, you had also
posted for office hours.
I think you have those--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DUANE BONING:
--tomorrow as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] to 6:00.
DUANE BONING: Tomorrow,
5:00 to 6:00, if you want--
any last questions
before the quiz--
Hayden's available
for those as well.
So thanks.
We'll see you on Thursday.